[Music]
so when we talk about openings in
strategy it already comes down to pawn
structure so I want to see the three
English games that we have today and
show more or less how the English is so
flexible that all the games look very
very different so I want to start over
here with the game between Magnus
Carlsen and max a Russian oligarch and
just notice how the pawn structure
really overtakes anything else on the
board even though we see that blacks
pieces are relatively active and he has
good positions for pretty much all of
them this pawn weakness on d7 this
Isilon II as we call it because it
cannot be defended by any pawn on its
side just creates these problems in the
long term basically here because there
are no good tactics Maxine had to
recover his pair of bishops and after
Knight takes c3 Queen e6 we immediately
see the problem with having an isolated
pawn and that's when you put a piece in
front of it
95% of the Carlsen played it's called a
blockade that there's just no way to
pass this pawn and it becomes a
permanent weakness even though here
Maxine doesn't have any particularly
immediate problems it's a very pleasant
position for the world champion because
in the long term there's simply no way
of fixing this the longer the game goes
the more dangerous it will be for black
to hold on to this phone here we have a
completely different scenario we have
the game between Wesley soul and
Alexander Greece Chuck and the position
of the plan seems symmetrical there's a
couple of differences first this pawn is
more advanced in this one and second
White has the pair of bishops in
symmetrical positions especially once
with an open file it's very key who can
control this open file now it seems like
there should be no problems white can
swing it rook to see one black and swing
the rope to c8 but in the long-term
scenario there's gonna be a problem for
black and that's because this bishop can
easily come to h3 at some point later
control the c8 square and this will
cause pawns for black in the very long
term notice that if black ever does this
he has to be careful of this on a post
long diagonal therefore he does want to
trade this bishops
but that would leave a night against the
bishop a bishop that controls a very
important key Square and a night that
doesn't necessarily have a job right now
white basically has a very slight
advantage which is completely risk-free
nice scenario for anybody in this kind
of tournaments and finally we go to this
confessional booth position of Levon
Aronian where he was mentioning here
after black captured Bishop takes on f3
how to recapture in this position you
could take with the bishop or with the
Queen as he was saying and enjoy a
little bit of an advantage we see that
the structure strongly resembles a
Sicilian dragon and many people actually
call this a reverse dragon position the
idea of taking with the pawn is that
first of all you take the pressure off
on the e-file no longer are you needing
to keep the knight on e4 to defend this
pawn second you are able to control more
squares that allows more flexibility in
the future for this pawn to come forward
but in chess
nothing's free here it comes with a
certain amount of risk if blacks ever
allowed to play this pawn all the way to
c4 it might force white to capture it
and it leaves black with an extra past
pawn also in the more immediate term
this bond could be attacked by a queen
or by a knight for example 9075 at some
point and it can become a weakness so
definitely context of three is riskier
but at the same time much more ambitious
than taking with either one of the
pieces a lot of strategical subtleties
in today's games three english openings
that are completely different but all
come down to the same thing pawn
structure dictates the strategy of the
game